votre deuxième question d'art il a
répété jean d'ormesson
la deuxième question monsieur seule
chine et il c'est qu est ce que vous
pensez de cet occident dans lequel vous
avez été plongé après tant de malheurs
et que vous connaissez maintenant je
pense assez bien mais je crois bien que
si jean daniel ou pensais que tu me bout
dans les gens derrière vous pensez que
je vais expliquer vous pensez que nos
régions je redis une fois de plus on est
secouriste donne patienter et
quelques-uns que la douleur et la
douleur d'un certain nombre de mes amis
le mot douleur n'est pas une inflation
sémantique c'est pas un excès de
vocabulaire c'est une prendre tellement
part à votre combat d'avoir une telle
admiration pour votre combat solitaire
de témoignages et de voir que sur ceux
qui a correspondu à vos combats en
occident il ne change
et depuis quelques minutes je suis
certain que vous vous trompez vous vous
trompez peut-être par simple manque
d'information alors pensez vous être
bien informé sur l'occident si vous
voulez une phrase pour vous préciser
puisque votre visage me donne une
impression de manque de clarté de ma
part je veux dire qu'il ya eu des même
combat que ce que vous avez menée chez
des gens qui n'avaient pas le génie
littéraire ni la détermination mais et
qui ce qui ne s'était pas des combats
contre le communisme
c'étaient des combats contre le
colonialisme c'étaient des combats
contre le capitalisme et que ces combats
là ils sont les mêmes que les vôtres
et c'est dans la construction d'un
avenir commun que nous nous voulons un
ton est d'intégrer le vôtre et tout d'un
coup voilà distant de vous alors que
pendant un an avec vos oeuvres
j'ai vécu avec vous là là vous avez
encore de réponse à faire
mais ça je vous la regardez ça veut dire
chose est sûre ni coupé de jean
d'ormesson ne peut pas laisser passer ça
n'y a rien n'est jamais prétendu avoir
été dans le nord avez vous savez
convaincre aux gens dans les rues des
gens qui mené le même combat
jean daniel jean d'ormesson vous avez
d'autres occasions de parler la
télévision à l'essence d'un milliard au
chili au portugal des gens ont mené le
même combat
oui ou non en france et j'adore une
salle de lampard en sologne à l'isthme
de colonialisme en indochine soudan avec
le colonialisme et le capitalisme
je parle aussi d'une durée de 20 minutes
et on le sait je vous le dis ça mais si
vous venez de dire quelques mots
voilà il a notamment noté cependant que
des amis et moi je prétends être plus
proche sur certains plans et pierre daix
là sur le monde et ne fait pas du tout
je ne sois pas tous les sujets il
accueille pour ce génie dit excusez moi
je suis maman garçons en france je le
faisais en 46 aux normes ce alexandre
ribeiro de parler notre foi semenov
alors que paris peine à arrêter
d'insulter j'en suis pourquoi sur le
congé dans le hpc de dynamiser tout le
monde a fait un mal on appuie les russes
comme le divin lancement de discovery
est un sens qui est nommé m'ont dit de
me dire c'est que il ne restait quelques
minutes comment prochaine quatre
périmètres
en partie gesterra débats n'ont répondu
d'occident détails mais je vais y avait
plus qu elle voudrait de poser une
question qui se rapprochent pour aller
plus vite la question sur l'espionnage
iakounine qui s'attirent ski je suis un
écrivain louis fils at il eu qu'à tonnes
de maïs ou du bas et si donc prévenir
tombés sur les deux français étaient
également ardent que nous vaudra the miz
mais yannick à skype a signé et il est
bien évident que je ne l'avais jamais
dit que ce soit avec ce que je puis dire
de l'oriental années passent mais si j'y
suis et je ne leur ai jamais non plus le
matériel divers des amis m'avaient pas
classe je puis vous gêner la lanière et
pêchu n'y a jamais un scooter gestione
bien telle oeuvre sérieuse azattyk que
sur les tigers n'ont pas suisse johann
attendri gino je consacrerai le reste on
a des manières nash à venir la gestion
de nos problèmes de notre pays
st